[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
blasé oralement être aveugle c'est une
tragédie qui nous approchent de l'ama
c'est une tragédie bien plus importante
que la surdité et cette tragédie touche
des millions de personnes dans le
moindre 45 millions de personnes sont
aveugles
rien qu'au hand on a 12 millions d'un
bug est ce qu'on essaie de faire avec un
ravine c'est de s'occuper de ses 12
millions d'aveuglés pour tenter d'en
réduire le nombre
on voudrait passer de 12 millions à 0
pour que ces gens puissent trouver un
travail
la joie et la lumière et la lie
[Musique]
il est 6 heures du matin devant
l'hôpital
aravinda iker de madurai au sud de
l'inde l'hôpital que govinda panne
hatcher a fondé avec son frère il ya 35
ans comme tous les matins des patients
font la queue par centaines
riche ou pauvre ils n'ont qu'un seul
espoir retrouvé la vue grand mère vous
avez déjà fait une opération de l'oeil
droit
maintenant on doit vous faire le gauche
vous avez l'habitude de voir sans
lunettes mais il faut faire vite cette
opération car vous ne voyez plus qu'à 1
m si on attend ça risque de réduire
encore en tant que médecin quand tu
mesures le problème de la cécité tu te
sens coupable quand tu vois des aveugles
le long de la route tu te sens coupable
de ne pas pouvoir faire quelque chose
voilà le facteur déclenchant la majorité
des aveugles en inde souffre de la
cataracte un durcissement du cristallin
qui devient opaque et vous rend aveugle
en inventant un système opératoire
simplifié à ravine permet à toutes les
couches de la société indienne jusqu aux
plus démunis de retrouver la vue j'ai
commencé à opérer quand j'avais 25 ans
est à 58
je me suis arrêté je n'ai jamais compté
mais j'ai beaucoup opéré dans les jours
bien compris je pouvais faire jusqu'à
100 opérations par jour
entre temps on a opéré près de 4
millions de patients dans nos hôpitaux
le d'autres personnes aveugles pour
cause de cataracte est passé de 85 à 60
% en 2010 c'est un changement
remarquable
regardez la lumière monsieur on va
commencer l'opération pour que tout le
monde en profite
govinda pas créer un système de paiement
solidaire dans lequel les plus riches
financent en partie les soins des plus
pauvres
sur 200 mille opérations annuelles 50%
sont gratuites 20% sont à un prix en
dessous du marché et seul un tiers des
patients paient un tarif normal
un modèle rentable qui dégage chaque
année des bénéfices réinvestis pour
construire de nouveaux hôpitaux
[Musique]
le principal c'est d'éliminer la cécité
si on souhaite en faire un commerce on
aurait travaillé qu'avec les riches
on ne voulait pas ça si on travaillait
qu'avec les pauvres on aurait été
dépendant de dons et je ne le souhaitais
pas non plus donc on a décidé d'avoir un
hôpital qui accueille ceux qui peuvent
payer comme ceux qui ne le peuvent pas
l'argent n'apparaît jamais sur mes
relevés
seul compte le nombre de patients je ne
veux pas savoir qui paye ou qui vient
gratuitement balle qu imaginer que je
sache qu'ils payent j'enlève toute idée
de justice d'espèce je sais combien on a
deux patients peu m'importe s'il paye ou
non je veux juste être sûr que l'on
traite un maximum de personnes
c'est tout ce que j'ai besoin de savoir
c'est le nombre important de patients
qui permet de dégager des revenus
et ça marche son hôpital considéré comme
un des meilleurs au monde pour ce type
d'opération reçoit des malades de tous
les continents
la trouvaille de govinda pas tourner
autour de cette lentille artificiel
pendant l'opération
le cristallin est remplacé par cette
lentille mais son prix exorbitant
réservé l'opération à la seule élite
indienne govinda pas a dû trouver une
parade des noms qu'ils étaient 2 500
dollars pièce online c'était impossible
d'en acheter car une opération entre 10
et 20 dollars
alors on a décidé de faire nos lentilles
nous mêmes pour faire baisser les
grosses sans changer la qualité du
grenelle on a acheté la technologie à
l'étranger et on a fait nos lentilles
pour bien moins cher
les prix sont passés de 500 $ pièce à
300 puis à 200 et maintenant une
lentille en inde coûte entre 2 et 8
dollars
les expos on exporte nos lentilles dans
de 140 pays et cela a eu pour
conséquence de faire baisser les coûts
des lentilles duda toutes les grandes
compagnies en plus des lentilles govinda
pas s'est lancé dans la fabrication de
lunettes vendues dans ces hôpitaux
certaines paires ne coûte que quelques
centimes pour govinda pas personne ne
doit être laissé sur le bord du chemin
[Musique]
écoutez moi bien pendant la journée vous
allez porter des lunettes vous allait
ressembler à l'acteur regini quant au
début vous serez timide mais regardez
cette grand mère elle a l'air génial
avec ses lunettes
elle a un vrai style alors la journée
mettez vos lunettes
d'accord on espère que nos yeux vont
aller mieux et on espère aussi que le
docteur se porte bien qu'elle vive
longtemps car c'est un dieu pour nous
elle nous a redonné nos yeux
mais
[Musique]
dans un pays grand comme cinq fois la
france govinda pas a déjà construit cinq
hôpitaux 40 centres d'accueil en pleine
campagne et elle organise des
consultations itinérante des hangars
sont transformés en cabinet munich au
géant
les villageois font des centaines de
kilomètres pour un rendez vous qui leur
coûtera 30 centimes d'euro
[Musique]
et 80% des gens vivent à la campagne et
80 % des médecins sont en ville alors il
n'y a aucune connexion entre ceux qui
ont besoin de services et ceux qui en
offre
[Musique]
vous avez une cataracte au 2ie monsieur
il faut opérer le gauche puis on fera le
droit on va partir pour l'opération si
vous avez des questions demandez à
l'infirmière je suis un peu stressé ne
soyez pas stressé l'hôpital va s'occuper
de tout on va vous nourrir et beaucoup
de gens vont prendre soin de vous et
vous avez l'espoir de voir c'est ça
l'important
oui j'espère qu'un jour je pourrai avoir
j'ai fait un long chemin pas ça
[Musique]
jamais imaginé devenir si on a commencé
dans un petit espace avec douze lits et
albert en quelques mois on ne pouvait
plus faire face à la demande
on a dû s'agrandir on est passé à 48
puis à 100 200 400 lits aujourd'hui on a
quatre mille lits et ce n'est toujours
pas suffisant et là on redonne la vie et
la lumière aux gens
[Musique]